we are back with the one and only Mario
Cantone and it's pie time we just
Mario and I did a demo on how to make
this beautiful sweet potato pie that
we're about to try right now yeah I I
would like to publicly say Patti LaBelle
come on let's have a cook-off hers is
the number one selling I know it as well
and I love her but you know she can out
sing me but I'll tell you oh my God come
on oh whoa
oh wow that's a good pie we lived in New
York since the 80s since the 80s I just
moved here like I guess um about seven
eight years ago and I've been coming
here since 1982 but I never felt like it
was my home because I lived in
California and that was like my anchor
yeah it's like a travel and go anywhere
I needed to for work but I would always
come back to this like same zip code and
now I'm so now you're here I'm so in
love with this I'm glad you found it I'm
glad you love New York I love the state
I feel like such a like I get the pride
that people feel about the tri-state
area I've got it and I'm from
Massachusetts originally so you know I'm
I'm uh
East coaster and but I I went to LA off
to college and I you know I really like
that I I liked I had no car no agent I
would walk up to The Comedy Store and
audition that's where my mom worked when
um when I was before I was born that's
where your mother worked really that's
the Troubadour and the comedy
yes which is like where all the
legendary Comics oh that's where we you
know should be partying with Jim
Morrison and Steve Martin wow
I moved here in 83 because I was like I
was I I I just I knew this was where I
remember New York in 86. well the eight
well the it
Chelsea it was
it was it was very it but you know what
Times Square was so different and it was
just like Hollywood Boulevard I was like
oh x-rated movie theaters uh-huh oh no
question I'm home it's exactly what it
was it was all x-rated all right we have
to Talk About Sex in the City because
you do it's I mean
who here feels like they
grew up grew into themselves and became
one of the four characters multiple
rotation times throughout their life how
many were you well it's definitely a
Samantha when I was younger
um and I think I mean everybody's a
carry because she represents all of the
romance I tried to be Charlotte York for
a decade I mean I know every episode
every piece of dialogue every word
inside and out do you have any like
behind the scenes stories well you know
when when we did when we did the the
second movie and I got married to my
beloved uh
Liza Minnelli uh Eliza Minnelli married
us it was the you know it was the gayest
I was it working with Live Well I know
Liza Minnelli because I I do her yeah I
do you do I do I do I do her it's I did
Sex in the City too
and I danced into my Santa because my
hip was killing me
yeah
you're welcome but she was she sang A
Cole Porter song for the whole crew
called every time I say goodbye that was
amazing but you know I I don't know if
they filmed it but it's not in the movie
but it was just something she did for
the crew in the castle and you got to
experience in the room yeah I've talked
to you about
one of my favorite moments um oh it like
really rips me apart when it does it's
just I think everybody's been through
this moment it's when Trey and Charlotte
agreed to break up that he shows up for
the photo shoot to be on the cover of uh
house and Gardens yes yeah and it just
it's like we all have that moment where
we know something is ending but we put
on a brave face and it was so well
captured in that moment it was so
Universal the things that the show takes
you through friendship love life loss
it's everything it's our lives and it's
done in a way where you believe that you
can connect with people and it lives on
you know no one has ever let the show go
it's like it really lives on I'm just
thank you for well you know what you
know Anthony was you know Anthony was
there he came in in season three I only
did 12 episodes
to stay on the show were you no idea no
I did one one I did one I had I had one
I'd filmed two scenes the second one was
cut and it was the scene where I was
trying to dress on her and she was very
anxious and I ripped it accidentally and
we had a little bit of an argument so if
that stayed in I might not have come
back but they cut it so that's what
happened but I only did 12 episodes over
the last four seasons but the two movies
kind of solidified it but this iteration
of it and just like that has deepened
Anthony and made him uh a much more
forward character and I am so thrilled
about it because I'm telling you when I
get those scripts even when even in the
past the way Michael Patrick King and
those right is right for this character
and every character but selfishly for me
it's just like I can go to work and just
be so thrilled about the words that come
out of my mouth he's amazing I think
it's safe to say that the world and
Society has decided that we don't want
life without this group this yeah this
gang this family this force and I love
that they're adding to it I'm in love
with the new characters and it was like
a big change change of oh my God here
comes new people and I'm like oh I'm
totally in but it needed it it changed
with the times absolutely brilliantly
changed with the times and and this new
season is going to be uh pretty
thrilling and fun I'm very happy
I cannot wait Mario I love that you came
here thank you so much Mario
[Applause]
message for this very important day
we'll be right back thank you
[Music]